we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a fair question about joe biden
and it sort of relates to our
conversation earlier let's take a listen
to it
um david i would i just wanted to know
what were your main critiques of biden
policies um i just wanted to notice
going into the 2020 election knowing
like
what do you disagree with him on
thank you got it okay so listen there's
no way to sum this up in one segment but
every time i've done an analysis of a
joe biden proposal
joe biden's health care proposal joe
biden's tax plan
joe biden on climate or whatever else
i will point out where he falls short
and i think what's important here is
context
so for example joe biden's tax plan
is actually quite solid it has a lot of
very good things in it it doesn't for
example
create new higher tax brackets i think
we need right now the highest tax
bracket i think is around 550 000
we probably need tax brackets like at
the 1.5 or 2 million dollar level
5 or 10 million 50 100 you know we need
higher
levels and higher tax rates at those
higher
levels he doesn't do that that's a
critique of joe biden's tax plan
and joe biden's tax plan does a lot of
good things when we looked at
joe biden's clean energy and climate
change plan it does
many good things but it fell short in
some areas
in terms of uh certain requirements
pollution requirements
you know i outlined them in that clip
when we've talked about joe biden on
health care joe biden's plan
will give way more people access to
health care and it will make health care
affordable for way more people
but it's not going to be comprehensive
and universal as an example so
with all of these questions the reason
i'm doing this is
that's it feels to me that that
voicemail was a good faith question it
was not a question meant to
do this stuff of if it's not bernie then
who cares if it's trump
it seems like it's just i'm curious
where do you disagree with joe biden and
i disagree with joe biden
in many areas and yet the reality that i
must vote for joe biden
is not missed at any point in time and
it is abundantly and completely clear
and my critiques of joe biden have not
been done in a way
to even remotely suggest maybe we stay
home or vote for trump
joe biden's plans don't do everything
that we want them to do
taking the senate in november in
addition to winning the white house
would best enable us to have two
straight years two solid years
during which we can push the senate and
the house and joe biden
to pass as much progressive change as
possible and that's all we can really
say right now and so my goal from here
on out is
i have no problem critiquing joe biden's
policy where it falls short
and that's what i do if i wasn't doing
that i really would be doing you a
disservice
but i'm not going to do it in a way that
might leave anybody thinking
whoa is david sort of saying maybe we
don't vote for biden no i'm not going to
do that it's going to be made clear in
every single segment that that's what
has to happen
we have a great bonus show for you today
now i actually i don't know
pat had a very interesting incident over
the weekend and i wanted to talk to you
about it
uh although i don't know that we're
doing it today so we may have some very
interesting stories on the bonus show
today about golden bitcoin prices
spiking and trump's executive order on
drug prices and some other things
or we may have a wacky pat ford story
from the weekend that i think you're
really really going to love
um but i'm just not sure yet because
i've got to figure out which bonus show
we're doing today in any case
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinedpakman.com or becoming a patron
at patreon dot com slash david pakman
show we'll see you then